Recently,
I was trying to decide whether or not I
should buy a wide angle lens for this
camera and in order to make that
decision,
I employed the timeless technique of the
pros and cons list.
In the process of making that list,
I happened to discover that the pros,
cons,
lists,
technique,
something so simple that it had to be
used by a human since time immemorial is
actually a relatively recent invention
by none other than our stupidly
accomplished forefather Benjamin
Franklin to somewhat hilarious.
Letter to Joseph priestly in 17,
72,
Franklin explains it thusly.
My way is to divide half a sheet of
paper by a line into two columns,
writing over the one pro and over the
other con than during three or four days
consideration.
I put down under different head shots,
hints of the different motives that at
different times occur to me for or
against the law.
When I had that got them all together in
one view,
I endeavored to estimate their
respective whites.
I'm going to act accordingly.
Now,
Franklin may merely
have been the first person to write this
idea down,
not the first to use it when it got me
thinking about concepts that appeared to
me as timeless,
but which only seemed so because I'm
trapped in this particular place at this
particular time.
For example,
the number zero,
we use it every day in conversation,
none,
Nada,
Zip,
Zilch,
zero goose egg,
but as a concept zero took many
centuries to develop and a number of our
greatest minds to comprehend fully the
best mathematicians of ancient Greece
didn't even have a name for zero.
It didn't like it does for us.
Serve as a place holder for writing big
numbers.
It wasn't until 6:50
add that Indian mathematician,
Brahma gooped finally formalized how to
reach zero through addition and
subtraction that the concept took shape
and it wasn't fully understood for
another thousand years when Newton and
live nets invented calculus and what it
actually means to divide by zero from
Matt.
Totally normal segue to sex,
though heterosexuality is something we
invoke to an almost ridiculous degree in
contemporary society.
The term actually dates to the mid 19th
century and a letter written by
Austro-hungarian journalist Carl curt
bent in the letter carrier,
Benny coins,
the terms for Hetero and homosexuality
as a way to suggest that there's no
hierarchy between the two ways of life,
that they're just different inborn
expressions of sexuality.
It wasn't until later in the 19th
century that psychiatrists and
psychoanalysts established
heterosexuality as a synonym for normal
and homosexuality is somehow deviant.
Before that,
people were persecuted for a certain
sexual acts like sodomy or pedophilia.
The creation and coopting of these terms
enabled the persecution of orientation.
Okay.
What about the idea of ambition?
Surely a timeless concept for admirable
striving up the social ladder.
Actually ambition is only as old as the
social ladder is.
It wasn't until the Middle Ages that
social mobility became a viable option
for members of society before the 16th
century social position was ordained by
God and classes were her medically
sealed part.
Nobody not born there could get in or
even entertain.
The idea of doing so.
Ambition comes from the Latin and beer,
which means to go around specifically to
go around canvassing for votes as in the
old Roman system.
In ancient times,
it was always used as a negative term
group together with pride and vainglory,
but when the middle ages ended and
modernity,
dawn,
the English word ambition enters common
usage as something positive to
legitimize and reinforce the social
climbing of the new world.
Fast forward to today and it's
impossible to imagine office spaces
without posters like this.
Finally childhood,
a timeless archetype of purity and
innocence known in the late 19th and
20th century.
Children were employed as laborers and
their work was seen as crucial to
contributing to the family income.
It was only after the passing of a
number of child labor laws that
prohibited them from work that society
began treating children in the way that
we think of now as explicitly
noncommercial,
as sacred,
imbued with an almost religious pure.
Instead of being individuals meant to
secure the future for their parents.
The roles were reversed and parents were
obliged to protect children from the
harsh realities of adult life and his
children's ceased to be productive
economic forces.
They reemerged in the economy as
consumers and the sentimental space they
occupied was aggressively
commercialized.
Before this shift in the culture,
the concept of childhood was much less.
Hello to the point that even the death
of a child was received with a certain
amount of aloofness and detachment,
zealous or quotes,
a contemporary man on this subject to
lose a child when first brought into
life is very hard,
but it is a tax we must pay.
It's an attitude that's hard to imagine
in a time like ours when the most
horrific and emotionally painful event
of recent memory was the death of 20
young children in Newtown,
Connecticut in 2012.
The majority of those who died today,
we're children,
a beautiful little kids between the ages
of five and 10 years old.
I'm not making a value judgment on any
of these shifts in our culture.
For me,
it's extremely humbling to know that my
conception of human nature is merely a
reflection of a moment in history.
Many,
if not all of these things are
historical accidents,
not some great fulfillment of the way
humanity was always going to advance.
They express the wills of individuals in
meshed in moralities as blind to the
past as we are.
The more we understand that fact,
the more benevolent our own blind push
forward will be.
Thank you all for watching.
This is my friend Maya.
She's here to tell you that if you are
interested in this topic,
there's a couple of other videos I did
in which I explored these topics.
One on concept of love and one on the
concept of logic and I'll put the links
here that you can click on.
Maya really wants to tell you to
subscribe to this channel,
follow me on Tumblr and twitter and make
sure that you stick around for the next
one.
Sorry I've been absent for the last
couple of weeks,
but listen,
there's important things going on.
He's back.
I'm back next time.